نعود الى الاخبار العاجله الوارده قبل
قليلة فدى مرسل الجزيره بسماع يدويه سلسله
انفجارات قويه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
انفجار احد الصواريخ في سماء المدينه
واطلاق كثيف لصواريخ الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه لاعتراضي لاهداف جويه كما سمعت
اصوات والانفجارات لدقائق فقط من اطلاق
صفارات الانذار واعلن عمده كييف توجه فرق
الانقاذ الى احد المناطق المستهدفه وسط
العاصمه هذا وهرع سكان المدينه نحو محطات
المترو واماكن امنه عقب الانفجارات وياتي
ذلك بعد هجوم ليلي مكثف بسبعه وثلاثين
صاروخا من طراز كروزا
وتسعين طائره مسيره تقول القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اعترضت سبعه وستين هدفا منها
المتابعه ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود من كيف ليطلعنا على ما يجري على
الارض في العاصمه كياف حول هذه التطورات
التي اوردناها في هذه الاخبار العاجله حسن
نعم ازدهار العاصمه الاوكرانيه تعرضت قبل
قليل لهجوم مكثف غير مسبوق منذ بدايه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وعلى ما يبدو
انها بصواريخ ايضا غير معتاده على العاصمه
نظرا لانه بعد سماع سفارات الانذار
بدقيقتين فقط سمع صوت انفجار قوي للغايه
في وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه تلاها ايضا
انفجار صواريخ في سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ثم اطلاق عدد كبير من الصواريخ التابعه
للدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه لمحاوله
اعتراض الاهداف الجويه التي تنطلق نحو
العاصمه الاوكرانيه هذا الهجوم ادى الى
سماع سلسله انفجارات
العاصمه نحن الان في احد المواقع التي
استهدفت في العاصمه الاوكرانيه نشاهد اثار
للدمار التي
ادت التي والذي خصفه
هذا الانفجار او هذا الصاروخ الذي على ما
يبدو انه سقط في هذا المكان فرق الانقاذ
تتعامل مع هذا الهدف
طبيعه المكان لا نستطيع الاصلاح عنها حتى
هذه اللحظه نظرا لحساسيه المكان لكننا
نتحدث عنه هجوم قوي بصواريخ على ما يبدو
انها سريعه للغايه وجهت نحو العاصمه
الاوكرانيه هذه الهجمه اتت بعد هجمه موسعه
مكثفه خلال الليله الماضيه
بعدد كبير من الصواريخ نتحدث عن اكثر من
37 صاروخا و29 مسيره الانتحاريه وجهت نحو
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وعدد من المناطق في
اوكرانيا بشكل متزامن اصبحت الدفاعات
الجويه كما تقول القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
67 هدفا جويا في سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وعدد من المدن الاوكرانيه من بينها مدن في
غرب اوكرانيا الا ان عددا من الصواريخ
السيارات وصل الى اهدافه على ما يبدو
الاداره العسكريه في خمرنت في قبل قليل
اصبحت عن معلومه ربما في غايه الاهميه
عندما اكدت ان منطقه عسكريه قد استهدفت
خلال هذه الهجمه الليليه من بينها منطقه
عسكريه
تشمل مدرجا للطائرات
وكذلك
تم اعطاب خمس طائرات كما تقول هذه
المعلومات التابعه للقوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن هجمات موسعه على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه وعلى اوكرانيا منذ
فتره منذ
بدايه شهر مايو تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه
ان 15
هجوما جويا وجه نحو العاصمه
الاوكرانيه خلال هذه الليله
عفوا خلال هذا الشهر منذ بدايه شهر مايو
وحتى الان
وفي ذات الوقت فان هذه الهجمات هي مكثفه
نعم الجيش يطلب منا المغادره من هنا سنضطر
الى المغادره لفتره قليله ثم نعود في
المتابعه قديم قديم يعود اليك اذا حسان
مسعود من كيف